we have a voicemail number good question
in this voicemail that number is two one
nine to david p voicemail caller says
hey there's a lot of crazy stuff going
on but like is any more money coming for
coronavirus because it's been four
months and we got 1200 bucks
david I was just really curious
especially with the end of the month
coming up we've only gotten one stimulus
package or direct payment to the to the
people yep wondering if you offhand knew
what percentage of this stimulus package
I mean everything including going to the
banks and all the the cruise liners all
these different companies yeah what
percentage of all of that went directly
to the people how much of our tax money
was dished out to companies compared to
how much did we get our money yeah so a
couple of things there I mean first of
all I believe that we had a sick I
thought it was six trillion total and
that two trillion was direct stimulus
and then a bunch went to specific big
industries and then a bunch was
available to smaller and big businesses
through PPP I don't have those exact
numbers and then the bigger question is
this started in mid-march for a lot of
people we are now in June for some
people this sort of started to ramp up
in February and places that took it
really seriously earlier is $1,200 gonna
be it or is there going to be some more
stimulus coming the second quarter
numbers second quarter being April May
June we're now in the third of three
months of the second quarter if we don't
start seeing recovery there has to be
more something more is going to have to
be done and the I mean you've got people
like Roe kana with proposals you have
other members of Congress with proposals
Trump's not talking about it is it this
just doesn't work
1200 bucks and unemployment only for
people who completely lost their jobs
it's just not going to cut it and one of
the things we will be talking about on
the bonus show today is that a lot of
the eviction freezes are expiring now
it's June first some eviction freezes
expire and people aren't going to have
money for the rent that's due today June
1st so we'll talk about that on the
bonus show we will also talk about my
more get instant access to the bonus
show by becoming a member at join
pakman.com it takes seconds and remember
to get our free daily podcasts the
one-hour podcast on iTunes stitcher
google play or any of your favorite
podcasting apps we are there grab that
daily podcast we love it